this again flashlights don't work like
this Welcome to Night people the current
number one rated game on itch don't know
what itch is then you've never looked in
the description anytime I've played one
of these horror games and that's on you
but people say this one's nice and
spooky so we'll see about that it's been
a while since I've been really spooked a
swindler got away with 25,000
the police pursued him and to escape he
decided to hide in an abandoned building
days later the swindler body was found
but his head and the money were not the
protagonist of this game decides to
visit the abandoned building and find
the
money well I mean I don't know about
protagonist that's making a lot of
assumptions here so let's just go out
and a limb and say the main character
we're not pro this guy money okay out of
25k
oh that's a weird
light see I'm not sure what's causing
that I don't know if the whole building
is undulating and that's just that's
just that but uh all
right sure I'm going
to I swear I I thought I saw something
down
there
you know what I can't see anything I'm
going to assume that I don't go that way
because that's that's what usually keeps
me alive I'm going to go up the scary
stairs
oh it's got kind of that body cam game
feel to it attention information is
requested on any member of the bendor
family they live in abandoned places and
have only been seen at night it is known
that they have formed a cult called the
night people where they they practice
cannibalism Witchcraft and
Satanism oh well all right to each their
own who am I to judge am I supposed to
go into the darkness
because what is
that is that just a shadow moving or is
there something
actually okay whatever I'm going in it's
dark you know what maybe not you know
what how about no okay do I have a
flashlight this is not work worth
it I don't care if I
got okay yeah
okay
okay yeah
ahuh what am I looking at what am I
looking at why does it look like it's a
dog's body but I think I see a human
head what am I looking at
what am I what am I looking at I need I
need like a zoom button I I don't like
this
[Music]
okay
oh what
what that's
fine
what
okay
hello yep you know what it was exactly
what maybe it's a
cat should I worry about the lights in
the dark oh you know what
I I ain't no
I apologize I apologize I thought it was
just going to be some random lights in
the darkness in the shape of I didn't
realize that's my
bad that's my bad that that's my
bad um oh oh yes
please oh this flashlight doesn't do
dick I'm pointing the flashlight in the
hall and there's still no
Hall that's not how flashlights
work what do you mean all right well I'm
going to go see what this thing was so I
I can apologize
properly
[Music]
aha
uh uhhuh oh what this again flashlights
don't work like
this I I never believed in
[Music]
Santa
I don't know why it's still
[Music]
occurring
okay this is where I would turn around
and immediately leave this is this is
just where it would occur this is where
that would happen and I refuse to do
anything else until I get the hell out
of
here let me
out let me out okay fine I'm going to go
upstairs I
guess and
I'll I don't know die or
something oh for some reason this
hallway Works a little
better in that my flashlight actually
kind of casts light a little bit but not
really
whatever listen chica I understand that
you think you've taken over the channel
but in reality this channel belongs to
me my name's on it I know I
didn't feed you on time this morning but
I swear I was
was uh I got busy who
okay all right well that's boarded up
and I can't see what's going on over
there this is
fine this is
fine this is fine this
is
fine fine
fine
fine oh
oh you know when I rounded the corner I
I was expecting like
something this is a lot more something
than I was
thinking but hey there's money yep yummy
yummy yummy
10K well godamn must be my lucky
day anyo oh
oh
hi is that you poochie chica is that you
oh who's a good girl who's a good girl
remember me
yeah I was only a few minutes late on
feeding you I slept in which is is that
good okay all right okay all right um
all right
bye sure wish I could see man it'd be so
good to see things oh
I see that good uh-huh great all
right okay a
person uhhuh shut up a
person a person associated with the the
Bender family with the Bender family has
been
arrested it is believed that he was a
member of the night people
cult during the
interrogation the individual mentioned
series of absurd events such as having
seen members of the Bender family
transform into
dogs which be super
weird
Papa I guess I'll go this way now I
don't
know oh were you always
open oh you
weren't
yippe I like
money I love money do you think that one
room down there on the left is open now
or what do I what do you think what do
you think about that what do you think
hey hey I love
money that's not the room it was all the
way down here oh no still stuck all
right okay see you later maybe the one
down here is open
now nope that's still boarded up I'll
try
downstairs it don't mind
me not so much night people as like you
know werewolves and
[Music]
whatnot f f you f you you think you're
going to give me with stuff like that
you didn't there's no proof you didn't
give
me you didn't give me no I wasn't got
lie oh it's a
circle any
who so
uh oh it's gone fine okay so the the
weird thing floor is gone now that's
where I got the
flashlight okay good good this is the
hallway of pure darkness and where
there's
nothing great so what was even the point
of coming down here why did I need to
come back down I don't think I needed to
but um I don't
know don't know what that door is all
about
oh can't see
anything
oh oh oh oh
hey wow well that's convenient a
mine leave leave the building I mean I I
want to oh the key is in one of the
apartments on the second floor come and
get it oh you know I'll do
that ah yeah start the
thumps yeah get slandy man over here
that's what we need that'll make it a
party
oh well that looks that doesn't look
very
threatening that doesn't look
threatening at all freaking oblong doggo
over
here
uh-huh
yeah I don't know what that supposed to
be I don't think that's a do
[Music]
oh ah good you still in here oh good
vacated the premises I'll take that
yoink time to go
home you didn't need to laugh with
me oh I'm running where I don't know I
can't see oh no oh I'm
running I'm skedaddling I'm schattling
here I
scle oh shoot oh God oh my
God uh oh uh oh it was all a
dream
hea no laughing this
time oh boy oh ye all right I I think I
went the wrong
way ah yeah yeah okay ah yeah okay all
right
okay I made it now I'm safe oh I can't
run anymore am I TI tired I can't
see oh
God oh God oh it's so dark oh it's so
dark oh man they couldn't have made
this they couldn't have made oh well
what is the point of even arguing about
anything when I'm about to imminently be
munched okay here we go I got a
consistent wall just to look
at oh sure
oh
sure oh
[Music]
sure what is never anyway what
wait what do I do what what do I do what
what what am I supposed to do
[Music]
here what what am I what oh there we we
go
okay it's a little
weird
and
end great good that was good that was
good I couldn't see anything but
honestly that created an environment of
dread which I will
uh remember thank you everybody so much
for watching this has been night people
um I'm starting to get back into a
rhythm of things which is really really
lovely and so videos are coming back in
if you didn't know I've been working
very hard on the movie um iron lung is
coming along and I know you guys are
eager for more stuff but uh it's
starting to settle into a good rhythm of
CVS finally came through for me I was
finally able to get a stars and get my
ADHD medication back which means that I
can kind of focus on a few more things
than just one in bashing my head against
the wall so that's nice uh thank you and
as always I will see you in the next
video
[Music]
bye-bye